what's happening there reject nation
greg and john here today we are going to
watch gravity falls episode something or
another hey thanks for being here and uh
if you can leave a like that'd be very
much appreciated also you know do that
thing where you subscribe and click that
bell that's also very much appreciated
full length watch along as we sync up
with the time code for gravity falls or
over at our patreon page you become a
super sexy reject today by checking out
all we have to offer there and also them
prepper boys thank you for helping us
edit down these highlights let's swing
into action people
oh no good night diner good night trees
good night tiny men stealing my pie
no
nose
ma'am
[Music]
little magic man
you won't believe what i've witnessed
it's oh
god
[Music]
well back to pie
weird [ __ ] happens all the time that's
close to eating you steve
there's still time
all right arthur
who are you
been there look what i got
yay a filthy green bottle it's a bottle
message from mermando remember oh yeah
part shirtless guy oh what if he wants
to get back together i wouldn't get your
hopes up mabel too late hopes are way
way up
huh
dear mabel so far so good it is with a
heavy heart so far so good
oh no
in order to prevent an undersea civil
war arranged wedding queen of the
manatees
oh
mermaid
look at my luck turned out to be gnomes
child psycho made out with his own hands
no
i wish i could just forget about them
forever
hey
is that what she's gonna do
i'm still trying to find the author of
this journal wait a minute dipper look
through your bottle just do it
do it now
mcgucket labs wait old man mcgucket what
so then that would mean
old man mcgucket wrote the journal
no
i can't get the terrible song out of my
head oh you mean straight blanching by a
little big dog it's a catchiest song of
the summer what is blanchin rappers
can't just make up words yeah they can't
oh sure they told me to eat my own pants
i would do it
let's do this
get out of here you saw it licking horn
swaggling
mcsuck it they got me good
come come pull up some rusty metal
you're just in time for my hourly turf
war with the hillbilly what lives in my
mirror
quit staring at me when i bathe no oh no
i'm no genius i've never done nothing
worthwhile in my life
everyone knows i'm no good to nobody
bullcrap here look closely i told you i
don't recall
everything before 1982 was just a blur
just a hazy
oh
what if mcgucket learned something he
wasn't supposed to know and someone or
something messed with his mind what is
the earliest thing you can remember the
history museum then that's where we're
going
sweet diggity the game is
oh
afoot
i paid 20 bucks for that cd
some guy on the street everything i look
at reminds me of my failed romances that
formaldehyde heart that romantic diorama
even this poster of my most recent
ex-crush
[Laughter]
oh
no
where did he go
i feel like all these eyeballs are
watching me they are
[Music]
what did they do to your memory man
we'll have to be stealthy i'll hambone a
message if there's trouble
i have no idea what that means hang on
to your sweet breads dip yeah i was
leaving the diner and i saw a little
bearded doodads and i was like
you won't be like why what is that gizmo
oh
yeah
guys are you seeing this they just wiped
lazy susan's memory
they should have wiped off that awful
mascara i think she looks beautiful
she's doing the best she can
seus
man i can't even remember what was wrong
or what i'm doing here or if i'm a man
or a woman oh your memories will be safe
with us
buried in the hall of the forgotten into
the hall of the forgotten oh my god all
right mabel wendy you two stay here and
make sure those robe guys don't come
back zeus you me and mcgucket are gonna
go find the hall of the forgotten
no there's someone there
what do we do where do we go
oh no
[Music]
oh my god why does every boy leave me
all those reasons boys are the worst you
shouldn't get hung up man what's your
opener pretend i'm a boy
testosterone
you should just forget about guys man
wendy that's it forget about guys
oh
you could accidentally erase like
learning to read or breathe man look at
all these tubes people must have getting
their memories erased all over town
whoa look at this
oh no robbie so i was attacked by this
magic kung fu guy that was throwing like
balls of fire at me i kicked his butt
though why are they erasing people's
memories i still don't get it looky
fellers it's those words what people
call me
i got it
i don't know mabel are you really sure
this is a good idea all ideas are good
ideas
yes
it's my philosophy
oh who's there oh no run
this way
get back here
oh you've really torn it up now
fiddleford this is all your fault
who are you bathrobe wearing freaks why
are you doing this well i suppose we are
going to erase your minds anyway
toby determined but gleeful no
how's that marriage going by the way oh
great great
not great and you've never met me
there's right there
you wouldn't remember i am blind ivan
and we are the society of the blind eye
the phrenology cranium gravity falls is
a town plagued with supernatural
strangeness so our founder invented the
next best thing
a way for us to forget now the people of
gravity falls go about their lives
ignorant and happy that's messed up in
fact your own sister was about to use
that rayon herself mabel seriously abes
don't you see this is ruining lives what
about old man mcgucket don't you feel
bad about that
not anymore huh
say goodbye to your summer no
if we're gonna forget everything i got
some stuff i want to get off my chest
mabel for half the summer i thought your
name was maple like the syrup i only
love some of my stuffed animals and the
guilt is killing me
no
i mean i'm supposed to be the smart guy
if i'm not the smart guy who am i
okay i'm not actually laid back i'm
stressed like 24 7.
oh stop being a bunch of babies
please is it oh my god
i raided the mining display for weapons
now fight like a hillbilly feelers kill
them go they know too much don't let
them escape
get this song out of your head
this and terry's gonna get you dawg
that's right mabel catch
i'll take that thank you
oh give it up boy you're no match for
the unstoppable power of oh
i don't wear nothing under my robe not
gonna apologize for that maybe y'all
should apologize for being a bunch of
prudes
well time to erase that forever
[Music]
by tomorrow this will all seem like a
bad dream
oh
my god
you took a bullet for me
oh
okay as i'll ever be
what why
listen
brain's too fried
my mind's been gone for 30 odd years
you can't break what's already broken
oh
choke him to death
whoa
headbutt
i'll jog some memories isn't so fun
being tied up is it hey want to draw on
their faces what
hey
that's where all the butt info goes
we'll never forget what you've done
oh i think you just might
say cheese
[Laughter]
what's my name where am i your name is
tutu mcbumbersnazzle your traveling
banjo minstrel yes
all right mcgucket are you ready to see
your memory he was always crazy wasn't
he we've come all this way go on
oh my god oh
sweet sarsaparilla
for the past year i have been working as
an assistant for a visiting researcher
he has been cataloging his findings
about gravity falls in a series of
journals
i decided to quit the project but i lie
awake at night haunted by the thoughts
of what i've done
i believe i have invented a machine that
can permanently erase these memories
from my mind oh
it worked i can't recall a thing
i call it the society of the blind eye
he created everything
oh
i would like to forget seeing this
i accidentally hit another car in town
today i feel terrible oh jesus no
my hair's been a falling out so i got
this hat from a scarecrow hey are my
pants on backwards
here's my
you kids helped me get my memories back
just like you said after all these years
i finally know who i am but now that
i've seen what happened i can begin to
put myself together again
oh
so wait you weren't the author but you
worked with him do you remember who he
was it's beginning to come back but i
need more time and reading glasses heck
oh
no do you still want to erase those
failed summer romances you know no one
likes having bad memories but maybe it's
better to remember the bad things and
learn from them than to go out denial
crazy trying to forget shut up you don't
know what you're talking about mabel
this mature that's me hey you want to
help me vandalize this picture of my
jerky x crush
yeah f that guy take that gabe
hey you know what going on this big
adventure actually made me get that
stupid song out of my head nice
it's almost like i can remember
all right you're getting close
i had a feeling
how to feel it's getting strong
no staniel
i don't care if it's dangerous i don't
care how long it takes i'm gonna pull
this off and no one's gonna get in my
way
uh
oh my god he's a villain
stan stands evil ah
stan's the author evil stan
grunkle evil
all right let's talk about it all right
guys well can't talk for too long
unfortunately especially for such an
important episode we're just going to be
super efficient with everything i
actually thought this episode was really
damn good i enjoyed it so much i think
old man mcgucket it was a character that
just very very very slowly grew over and
grew on to me it took a long time i
usually did not enjoy watching him he
was always kind of gross and creepy and
off-putting it's kind of the point of
the character um but i was never
charmed or found that funny but before
all the information started becoming
more revealed about him i thought it was
still humorous
over time and then here to really pull
back the layers to discover how
responsible he is for all those things
like that was such a twist i didn't
actually see coming i thought it was
just going to be he discovered a bunch
jotted it down and then now here he is
but into this to go the extra level
of how much he invented
how involved he was with creating the
society like he is the creator of it
was really surprising that was a great
twist and
so far what they've done with season two
has made me go like i wonder what the
re-watch of the show would be like uh
going back to season one was the first
time you meet old man mcgucket and seen
you know just the kind of character he
was and how he just meant for jokes and
stuff i was just like a loony guy crazy
guy
so i thought that how they handled his
character here was really awesome i
thought this was like an awesome twist
and
i appreciate how they went dark with the
society the society was really
i mean
yeah it's messed up yeah i i like the
idea of what they do and and it makes
more sense now how no one in ground
because it's always been kind of a
question like how do people in gravity
falls not
know things or or
are aware of just the craziness that
they're surrounded by or forget things
and then they
they answered that and so i guess part
of the the appeal of a re-watch is to
see
oh yeah that was there the whole time
you just didn't know
yeah that's a good point
so yeah johnny
take it away i agree with everything i
mean actually i i mean i've always found
mcgucket to be amusing if not you know
sort of a stock you know sort of wacky
cartoon
character that you would have in a show
like this but yeah it was really nice to
get that expansion and i just love the
inner workings of the uh society the
blind eye and just all the you know
different
things on display and little details
like that's another thing i would love
to go back through the show and catches
just all the little details and things
that are in the backgrounds and yeah in
the environments and and probably all
the clues as well and yeah i love that
they have this mystery ever expanding
and we get closer and closer we inch
toward it but we still have a lot of
pieces left to find i like that yeah it
wasn't mcgucket who necessarily wrote
the journals but he's a key
figure in their creation and in the
cataloging and logging of everything
that goes on in gravity falls and so
yeah they've managed to you know
seamlessly
develop
this sort of um yes
twin peaksy stone cuttersy kind of thing
going on in the backdrop and yeah i
think it's really clever i would wonder
i wonder
how in the production of the show like
what the intent was whether or not it
was to gradually get to this stuff by
like a season two or whether they had to
play ball and kind of split the
difference but either way i mean it
makes for really fun and rewarding
episodes as we're getting further and
further into the serial story so to
speak yeah an eternal sunshine of the
spotless blind's one of my favorite
movies ever so to kind of get some
reflections of that of the power of
painful memories
that it's not something that we should
just try to erase or be in denial of
that there's something to be learned and
gain from a painful memory i also think
it's a good lesson to instill in
children
and adults too
especially so many adults just kind of
go about life and try to forget and
repress so i think that this was uh
really just overall pretty damn good
episode i was really i was really into
it and i like when the four of them are
paired up you know mandy
um dipper mabel
my god
the guy who i now like
yeah
yeah they make a good scooby gang yeah
so yeah this was awesome this was
awesome i really appreciate this one but
guys what did you think about this
episode what was your first reaction
when you discovered this leave your
thoughts down below subscribe click that
bell leave a like and uh last but not
least let's do a patreon
the ogre man this is your shout out
because there's got to be some ogres
lurking in the gravity falls no all
right i mean you've gotta be somewhere
hidden in the lost pages of this journal
i mean dude there's gotta be so much
information that you could shed on your
people for us all right all we have to
go off of the shrek
that's it man that's the main ogre in
popular culture you're the ogre man
second character named ogre there's an
ogre yeah
very much more popular than shrek but
those are the only two so you know just
a popular fictional type of character
being you know
lowered as ogres and lord of the rings
that's fast so
apparently
you're a generic ogre ogre man i tried
to make you special but really i mean
what are you doing to separate yourself
from the rest of the olders all right
you know you can't let everybody else do
all the work for you all right you can't
let them trolls and things be confused
for your people either all right that's
not good it's a whole different kind of
mythical creature
you don't even need to ask riddles three
you know i think everyone was doing that
i
i think there's i think you know you
just want to cover all the bases
you are the most unique
you are like an ogre superhero no
because he's the ogre man and what does
what does the over man do you know it
protects people crossing under bridges
or through swamps
i guess that's that's what nobody
especially been trying to digest this
you know it looks a little more special
than that shrek
princeton i know any certain
songs by smash mouth hero
so oh yeah
you could be i mean what
you could be a swamp hero
or a
woodland hero appreciate this mountain
hero you need a good job shout out
special i feel special
[Music]
you